investing is investing in enterprises
that that work in the market typically
charge for their services but where the
investor is seeking social outcomes as
well as the financial return the answer
is yes but the answer is also it depends
in you can do good
in private equity and venture capital in
areas where you're bringing capital to
an enterprise that it otherwise wouldn't
happen you can also do good if you're
making what what sometimes called
sacrificial or concessionary investments
where you're expecting a below market
risk adjusted return the one area where
you can't do good is investing in large
cap publicly traded markets because your
investment just doesn't make any
difference in those markets you have to
decide what area you want to have impact
in whereas financial returns are
basically the same
whatever you invest in impact investing
on the social side requires a degree of
intentionality it's what do you care
about so I may care about improving
mobile telephony probably not in the US
but in Bangladesh you may care about
clean water in Africa and somebody else
may care about improving poor
communities in the US so each of us
would find different areas if there are
social enterprises in those areas that
we think are impactful each one of us
would find investments in those areas
if you're doing pure philanthropy you do
due diligence to see whether it's a good
felt good nonprofit organization if
you're doing pure investment you do due
diligence to see if it is going if it's
solid and is going to bring a financial
return if you're doing impact investing
you have to do due diligence for both of
those so it's it's a it's a it's a
tougher task whenever you're trying to
optimize on more than one outcome and in
this case it's both social social impact
and financial return is just harder to
find good opportunities one of the
things that makes an impact investing
fund or fund manager or individual good
at it is they have the same knowledge of
a particular market take sanitation in
Africa or health in India they have the
same knowledge so that that John Doerr
at Kleiner Perkins has of high tech
social media investments right so it
requires great knowledge of a domain and
then you see things that the world at
large doesn't see you see opportunities
and that that's where the trick is
a social impact bond it's it's a
terrible terminology I think one might
better call it sort of investor back pay
for success scheme because it has two
parts the first part is government
contracting with a service provider for
example somebody who provides homeless
service or who reduces recidivism among
youth let out of prison contracting with
them not to perform the service not to
counsel the people but for actual
outcomes so it's a performance it's a
performance based contract and that in
itself is fairly unusual in government
government contracts government tends to
support somebody just providing the
services and not measuring whether they
actually achieve outcomes so that's the
easy part relatively the second part
which is why it's called a bond is that
if you're if you're paying an
organization to provide services then
you can pay them by the week or by the
month of the quarter if you're waiting
for outcomes it's going to take years
before you actually know whether they
achieve the outcome so the question is
how is the organization going to have
working capital during this period and
here's the other part of a social impact
bond there are investors who will put
money into the organization during the
period that it's before it's a prove
success and then the investors get paid
back depending on whether the
organization succeeds
the investor or organization only gets
paid if it meets agreed-upon metrics so
the measurement of outcomes is in effect
built into that scheme so if you take an
example in Massachusetts the state
entered into a contract with an
organization called Roca and investors
to reduce recidivism below the existing
baseline right now if you're a young man
let out for prison in Massachusetts the
chances are 60% you'll be back in prison
within five years so the goal of this
particular arrangement is to reduce that
rate so you know what the rate the
standard rate is the baseline rate and
with the what the organization does is
they agree that they're going to reduce
it by some fixed amount and you only get
paid if you reduce it by that fixed
amount so the outcome is is really part
of the deal and I think that's a
terrific way for governments to work and
I think it's a terrific way for
nonprofit organizations which are all
often pretty sloppy about outcomes to
work as well I think it brings a
terrific discipline to to all the
organizations
I think that both impact investing and
the subsets social impact bonds it's
early days and I think that we just it's
it's quite possible that these are both
kind of flash in the pans they're fads
and it'll turn out that you can't
sustain investments in this area that
you can't find investments that are
going to make a return and that the
investors who are willing to take a
concession they're not enough of them or
they might do just as well making grants
so I regard both of these as really
interesting experiments but I'm not I'm
not a I'm not boost a booster of these
things I want to see where they go and
I'm just I'm an enthusiastic student if
it works you're going to find new ways
of financing social enterprises and
allowing them to scale in a way that
philanthropy alone can't do and if
social impact bonds work it will find a
new way of government being attentive to
outcomes and organizations being more
attentive to how it comes so I don't
know how great the upside probability is
but if it eventuates the upside is
terrific